et on nous sommes avec ali tounkara
directeur et fondateur du centre des
études sécuritaires et stratégiques au
fel bonjour à vous merci d'être avec
nous ce matin donc la cedeao qui a
dépêché une délégation au mali une
mission qui est achevée hier
est-ce qu'on a une chance de voir
réellement des élections générales se
tenir dans le délai de 18 mois
merci je pense que lorsqu'on regarde
aujourd'hui les différentes positions
dégagée par les acteurs en présence
notamment les ténors du mouvement n 5
qui serait à l'origine du départ de test
d'un kit a également c'est la classe
politico naturellement tous les sens
vous que cette position est
difficilement pourrait parvenir la
lumière des élections transparentes
surtout surtout acceptable notamment par
les pratiques politiques donc en somme
en ce moment phare de notre tradition
qui est déjà émaillé pas d'existence
vous voulez par l'exclusion est mort
alain sushi reyel de l'intimité
quant à la conduite la chatenet mort l'a
fait doute la position
c'est vrai qu'il ya beaucoup
d'inquiétudes de la part à des maliens
mais aussi du mouvement m 5
un mouvement qui regroupe plusieurs
organisations de la société civile sur
la mainmise des militaires
justement sur cette transition
quelle est la situation au melia
complètement à la lecture les actions
qui sont déjà conduite par cette
tradition des hypothèses sont plausibles
la première risquions d'assister à une
taille hissant sur l'eau dont ils les
militaires voire d'avoir amorcé les
différentes formes qu'elles soient
institutionnels s'activent ressemble
autant à se recycler mais effectivement
la classe politique en bonne partie la
suisse hull quand relation nippo thèse
consisterait à impliquer les acteurs de
la société civile ce qui était demandé
par la cedeao ainsi que la classe
politique mais là quelle implication
malheureusement
c'est d'amener cette rançon une
éléphante des différentes démarches qui
sont déjà un petit or on sait
qu'aujourd'hui un nombre important de
militaires penser que la classe
politique ne serait pas dans un combat à
landas les sens de l'intérêt collectif
des plus tôt cette phase critique elle
s'efforçait à comment asseoir sa
légitimité à comment asseoir ses
positions soit c'est des produits
malheureusement il n'est pas le peuple
malien assistait ce critère est
constitutif et surtout surtout nous non
pas quand même que ce soit la chronique
économique de la fleuriste ou de crise
acteurs qui se sont calmes et non celle
du mali depuis l'accueil 2012 s'inquiète
quand même ma quant à l'issue de cette
année sont pour des raisons liées à son
utilisation l'intimité et pour des
raisons liées justement assez des masses
ils sont jugés par les membres
importants des démarches et ce qu'ils y
va des démarches qui sont pas loin
qu'ils y voit notamment avec la classe
politique
or justement il ya donc là
l'organisation des futures élections en
question mais aussi la les discussions
autour de la révision constitutionnelle
là encore jugé insuffisamment inclusif
ces discussions actuellement
rappelons quand même que le président a
informé reconnaît aujourd'hui pour les
chefs d'état qui se sont succédé dans
les contextes aux maliens avaient tenté
de réformer la constitution les quelques
tentatives ont toutes échoué pour des
familles liées à la non activité pour
des facteurs liés justement surtout à la
connaissance du contenu de ces
différentes performances donc de la
polonité elle est même mort aussi forte
que cette année également se voir
contester
lorsqu'elle va commencer à l'effort ou à
réviser la constitution
même si les différentes prises de parole
le front est a déjà des actions qui vont
dans le sens de la révision de la
composition et des actions qui vont déjà
de l'essence lac des réformes
institutionnelles et administratives
je crois que l'hypothèse la plus
plausible mais pas les délais forme
nationale 1 cm certains morceaux
même si elle ne sommes pas inclusive des
élections vont être organisées mais pas
franchement des logements et l'équipe a
cette ambition
mais les élections sont certainement
contesté par une bonne partie de la
classe politique et gags déjà à la
cellule qui a été l'hommage qui a été
déjà mise en place par site a été la
position à laquelle se livre censé
justement organisé les élections est
censée justement même réformé la loi
fort mental électorale nos chanceux
aujourd'hui pour les autorités de la
transition
tout laisse croire que la taille et les
élections seront tenues dans les délais
tout l'esprit effectivement les
élections sont citoyens qu'ils mettent
en question un peu la classe politique
quand on l'interrogé l'opinion publique
malienne nom des buteurs et yellow
subsistent quant à eux limités quant à
l'heure surtout sous les consensus je
crois qu'aujourd'hui c'est qu'on peut
dire laisser l'autorité des connexions
elles sont certes bien intentionné mais
les démarches qui sont une spécialité
sont des démarches tout malheureusement
prévisible
on lui reproche aussi très rapidement
elle et on taira pas ce qu'on doit
terminer on lui reproche aussi des
arrestations extrajudiciaires
lorsque les stations puis on tourne ou
de tentative de coup d'état
sur les 1 station qui sont passés par le
nombre important des gist comme
arbitraire les arrestations sont perçues
par le nombre important des maliens
comme des règlements de compte c'est qui
est comme sur tous les projets ces
arrestations les lenteurs de la justice
les réalités la bonne parole aux
présumés putschistes disent pas que
lorsque son mandat dans les traditions
quitte aussi émaillé pas de polémique à
la fois tu n'as pas de politique et et
il est calme les responsables des sous
titres notés mission garde l'analyste
eric beaucoup plus visible de rendre la
saône à l'egypte est beaucoup plus
incluse ou même à logements tout
l'espoir que ces arrestations sont j'ai
dit merci beaucoup à l'époque haras
directeur fondateur du centre des études
sécuritaires et stratégiques au sahel